Workers of the world, unite!
Many people are excited about socialism.
They prefer it to capitalism.
So, it’s time for…
A new book, called “The Case Against Socialism”
You'd think you wouldn't have to write a book
to make the case.
That's what a lot of people respond.
They say, "Oh, the case against socialism?
Wasn't that decided?”
Senator Rand Paul wrote the book because
for these people, the case obviously isn’t decided.
Don’t they know socialism’s track record?
Hitler's socialism, Stalin's socialism, Mao's socialism.
You would think people would have recognized by now
Paul’s chapter titles highlight socialism’s problems
It leads to corruption.
It’s a boot stamping on the human face forever
"Because Eating your Pets is Overrated."
You would think that when your economy gets to the
point where people are eating their pets people might
have second thoughts about what type of
economic system they’ve chosen.
The eating your pets chapter points out that
Venezuelans have lost weight because they
cannot find food.
Contrast that with Dear Leader, with Maduro,
who's probably gained 50 pounds.
We don’t know that the dictator gained 50 pounds,
but he does eat on TV while his people starve.
It really sums up socialism.
There's still a well fed top one percent,
they just happen to be the government or those
who are cronies or friends of the government.
No Trump, no wall, no USA at all
American socialists say, we won’t be like that.
When I talk about Democratic socialism,
I’m not looking at Venezuela.
I’m not looking at Cuba.
I’m looking at countries like Denmark and Sweden.
They all wind up saying, "Ah, but the kinder,
gentler socialism that we want is Scandinavia.”
That’s the kind of socialism.
Democratic socialism in Scandinavia.
So we do a big chunk of the book in there
talking about Scandinavia.
Paul’s book is different from other politicians’ books.
Paul did actual research.
It's not true that
the Scandinavian countries are socialist.
While Scandinavia tried socialist policies
years ago, they then turned away from socialism.
They privatized industries and repealed regulations.
Denmark is far from a socialist planned economy.
Denmark’s prime minister even came to America
and refuted the socialists’ claims,
pointing out Denmark is now
A successful market economy with much freedom
to pursue your dreams and live your life
In fact, when experts rank economic freedom,
Scandinavian countries rank near the top.
They have private property, private stock exchange.
We learned that, actually,
Bernie is too much of a socialist for Scandinavia.
Scandinavia did keep some socialist policies,
like government-run health care.
The media say that brings huge benefits.
It’s why Swedes live longer. But...
This is the trick of statistics.
You can say, "Oh, well the Swedes live longer,
and they have socialized medicine."
And yet if you look hard at the statistics,
it started way before socialized medicine.”
60 years ago, Swedes already lived longer.
If you have sauna, you live longer.
Likewise, the socialist welfare state
didn’t reduce poverty.
Scandinavia’s culture did.
For me it’s really, really important to work
Swedes tend to work hard
Paul tells a story about
Nobel prize winning economist, Milton Friedman.
This Swedish economist comes up to him and he says,
"You know in Sweden we have no poverty."
And Friedman responds and he says,
"Well, yeah, in America we
have no poverty among Swedish Americans."
Today, Swedes in America have a much higher
standard of living than Swedes in Sweden.
Danish Americans too.
Socialism simply does not create that magic world of
prosperity plus equality that today’s socialists suggest.
But the biggest case against it
is that it crushes freedom.
Socialists get elected by promising fairness
and equality.
The only way you can enforce those things
is you have to have an equality police or
a fairness police,
and ultimately they show up with truncheons.
Tanks, tear gas, and riot police
Why does it always lead to
“a boot stamping on your face forever?”
If you want complete socialism,
you have to take the property from people.
Here’s Hugo Chavez doing that.
The best kind of socialist leader ends up
having to be ruthless because you can't be
a kinder, gentler socialist leader
and get the property.
So many choices!
By contrast, capitalism largely lets individuals
make our own choices.
It's a direct democracy every day.
You vote either for Walmart,
or you vote for Target.
You vote with your feet, with your wallet.
And the people who succeed are the people
who get the most votes, which are dollars.
And as long as there's no coercion,
seems to me that that would be the most just way
of distributing a nation's economy
At your service!
It’s good that Senator Paul is around to tell his fellow
politicians the truth about socialism:
It doesn’t work.
It’s a recipe for disaster.
Look what happens as we approach socialism
around the world.
It’s a history of famine and genocide.
When working families are under attack
what do we do?
Stalin, Hitler, Mao,
Pol Pot, Castro, Chavez, Maduro.
It doesn’t work.
Hope you enjoyed this video.
Please click that button to help us make more.